hey guys now there's a lot of people out
there that's trying to lose weight and
they put on all the effort to do it but
they don't realize that it's their bad
habits that is keeping them down that is
keeping them from losing weight so to
lose weight and to live a healthy
lifestyle you need to know your bad
habits that cause you to gain weight so
in this video I'm gonna talk about the
seven bad habits most people have that
makes them gain weight let's get to it
[Music]
mistakes by mistakes make you stronger
hey now if it's your first time here on
my channel I'm Daniel and welcome to t
LM model or lifestyle subscribe and also
click that notification belt so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's start with the first bad habit
that you might still be doing we've
already been realizing it it causes you
to gain weight
bad habit of eating too fast yeah I used
to do this myself all the time and I had
to force myself or train myself to take
my time and eat slower and to just enjoy
food that I'm eating a study from the
University of Rhode Island found that
people who eat slower eats one-third
less than people who eat fast why well
because it takes around 20 minutes for
your stomach to tell your brain that
it's full so if you're eating too fast
start to really just train yourself to
eat slower and try to chew your food
around 20 times or you swallow it
not a bad habit is eating or snacking on
snacks while you're watching TV or just
on your iPad TV series or movies you
know how quickly that bag of chips can
disappear yeah you know what I'm talking
about now the reason for this is because
your focus so much on what you're
watching that you're not focus on how
much and also what you're eating the
recent study from the University of
Birmingham shows the people who are
distracted eats 5 to 10 times more and
some people don't even remember
everything that they eat now most of us
are alright even me I'm very guilty in
this one right so I'm sitting here
telling you guys not to do it but I'm
doing it myself
but what I learned is instead of
bringing a bag or two or three you know
and you're just chucking it down focus
on just taking a bowl and throwing in a
small portion so in this way you know
exactly what you're eating and how much
you're eating of it and also instead of
choosing all those unhealthy stuff
choose nuts or even popcorn that will be
a lot better
all right next one taking big bites of
food the American Journal of Clinical
Nutrition shows that if you take big
bites of food you are consuming around
50 percent more calories than people who
takes smaller bites and chew it longer
so train yourself to cut your portion
sizes smaller and then you'll eat
smaller bites as well you can also use a
smaller fork smaller spoon and smaller
plates it's one of the things that I
learned while traveling all these years
to Asia you can see that a lot of Asians
are skinnier than we are in South Africa
and even in most of the Western
countries and there are there's a lot of
reasons for this but one of the reasons
is they eat out of smaller plates than
we do so they eat less food now this is
a very important one because most people
still do it and they don't even know the
consequences of doing it so what is it
the bad habit of always eating low-fat
or fat-free food Daniel why is this bad
well you buy in because you think that
it will help you to lose fat right well
the food industry knows this and that is
why they keep on selling it as low-fat
and fat-free so they take out the fat
content right
but winnings we need taste and we eat it
it tastes it doesn't taste as good so
what is the solution because they need
to sell the products because they want
you to like it right so that added a lot
of sugar so most of the fat-free and
low-fat products that you buy you're
actually just buying products with more
sugar in it which is a lot worse for you
and when you eat it it digests faster
and it gives you a sugar crash and
remember a healthy fat is a lot better
and healthier for you then sugar fat
free does not mean calorie free
not getting enough sleep now if you've
watched most of my videos you're
probably realizing by now just how
important good sleep is for you for so
many different reasons because well I
talked about it in so many videos right
but why is it a bad habit for you if you
don't sleep enough
well not sleeping enough makes you feel
hungry even though you are full because
sleep loss affects your hormone cortisol
which regulates your appetite not only
that but sleep loss also increase the
fat storage in your body so start to
develop a new habit of getting a good
healthy sleeping kriti never go grocery
shopping when you're hungry yes most of
you know what I'm talking about here
right then you're hungry but you still
need groceries so you go to the grocery
store and you want to buy something and
but everything you see look so good even
if it's unhealthy but you're hungry and
you just want it so you buy and you eat
it and afterwards you feel so guilty
right yeah so try to eat something
that's healthy in something that really
fills you up before you go grocery
shopping drinking something before
thinking I can explain this all right ok
coffee I drink a lot of coffee I like it
it's healthy and I know how to control
myself alright but I'm not talking about
me now I'm talking about you guys all
right but in all seriousness I can't
believe that I used to do this when I
was younger you know soft drinks coke
and whatever even juice of sugar in it
beer he's so easy to just take it
Chucky's down but we forget and we don't
realize just how quickly those calories
stack up so you got to break away from
this bad habit even better stop drinking
any of those soft drinks because it
really is so bad for you apart from
making you fat it causes diabetes and
heart disease and it puts a lot of
stress on your pancreas but all right
you get the picture right there's a lot
of videos here on YouTube that you can
check out or we'll show you and explain
to you just how bad these soft drinks
really are
if you're not sure how to maintain a
healthy nutritional lifestyle check out
this video and subscribe to my channel
and we will talk soon Cheers
[Music]